i'm just gonna dive straight in if
that's okay because we're running a
little bit late um
what i wanted to do with you today is as
much for us as hopefully for you um i
really wanted to explore the whole idea
of community
and where the barriers to
decarbonisation might lie
and
kind of pull through to these
sustainable development goals as well
and see kind of what we feel about
energy so
the first question i wanted to ask you
very quickly was
what is community
nice easy one to start with
so what what do we what does community
mean what is it how do we define
community
give it to the dyslexic
any other kind of ideas about what
community might mean
or is
it's like asking questions i know i was
just thinking the same thing
they were like we thought we were gonna
sit here and watch a presentation um
okay so let's move on to another one
maybe come at it from another another
angle huge shapes and defines your
communities
who does that who makes up that fabric
that is your community think of the town
where you live or the village where you
live
what is that community we've been
talking about community energy in
communities all day so what is this this
thing community
i think this is sort of like
twofold to it from from my point of view
um
from where i am in terms of probably my
age somebody 20 30 years old and i might
see it differently but i see it's all
too too strange you've got kind of your
community leadership
that
depending where you live maybe more
visible than others
and perhaps all those groups that make
up the community so your schools um
maybe a church
uh your local businesses yeah even if
it's a handful of you know post office
up in a few village shops and
maybe you've got a really strong farming
community and your play group is part of
your community perhaps you've got a
a local health center that's that's your
community too
and then as you say all those people
um who don't maybe come into the
community in such a visible way
and
so when we're kind of thinking about how
we access
uh sharing the decarbonisation
message
um
how do we go from the community the the
local government
down to the parish councils which may be
um those same five people
who talk to each other and do all the
stuff how do we get from those five
people to the rest of what is
essentially in reality the community and
get
an engagement at that level at that kind
of grassroots level and
[Music]
what kind of things matter to our
community
do we even know that if you think of
your own place where you live what
matters to the people who live there
what are there
concerns and issues
is it an affluent community do you live
in a village of people who may be
retired there do you live in a community
where
um
there are a lot of affordable homes and
people who may be struggling
um financially
or maybe have difficulties in terms of
you know a long commute and they're not
really around or available at the
weekend or in the evenings to
participate in community discussions
and so i think that's kind of what i
want to throw out there at the back of
your mind
whilst we start to explore those
challenges to decarbonization
is it that communication
is
magazines church magazines
and that that sort of thing to come
across and there's a lot more
decentralization in the way of
communication by newspapers
so picking up and running with that if
you look at
something that struck me that ian said
um this morning when he did his keynote
and he said how he he was introducing
john taylor and he was saying how he
keeps up to date with what john is doing
on twitter
so
millennials so anybody 40 and under who
lives in your community
most of their community is actually
online and most of the conversations
they're having might be on facebook and
if they're organizing something
literally within the community it's it's
through that that they'll find out about
it or be doing it if you're younger
snapchats instagram um now all of these
things
yes or 20 seconds on tick tock yeah
climate changes sucks be here at this
time
school strike
end off no great kind of hyperbole and
massive discussion
yeah
so
do we need that communication or kind of
personally said about five people
and in community volunteer fields as
well
how do you get those marginalized people
those disenfranchised people whether
they're young or old or wherever how do
you get those involved and how we
we know that
um
that sense of ownership in your locality
is meant to be best that's why these
these community energy schemes are
probably going to work very well so
but it's really difficult when we just
spent 20 months isolated and people's
communities are virtual communities and
they may not be localized whereas our
answer and we go back to 25 years ago
actually we'll see global well
21 yeah it was absolutely such a long
time ago that that's first yeah that's
the whole tree i would just like to say
[Music]
but i still don't feel like there's much
visibility i know there's lots going on
community wise
but i don't feel like
they're shouting about it enough or if
they are i'm not seeing it and so it's
the visibility of what's going on what i
could get involved in it
and then
potentially not so much
in case grave but i think when i was
younger and in the past and for example
say
at university age
they're
kind of kind of being involved in your
community and
being a driving force
especially then and still a little bit
narrower quite a lot now it seems just
quite fuddy-duddy i think okay
yes i hear what you're saying and i
think people i think people on parish
councils who are of an old older adult
because they're retired so they're able
to give their time to it would probably
be thoroughly delighted to have younger
blood come in so straight away there's a
there's a disconnect here isn't that
sorry i'll come back to that
just recently been involved in trying to
recruit a couple of cleaners for a
village hall
and we were discussing how we are
advertised
and we found about eight channels
through which we were going to
advertise these vacancies
i'm not sure there's a communication
problem
in the issue we're talking about
i think the problem is that most people
think it's too big
and just
shut that's great yes
yeah but it's too
the the whole problem is too huge
to deal with yeah
yeah i think
community is a very
um
[Music]
interchangeable world word because it
can apply in all sorts of different
contexts whether it's
a parish or a university or
village or town but i think what makes a
community may be
a shared sense of responsibility or a
shared interest
and whatever that is
it's it's it's obviously
it's that thing
that brings people together to work
together because they want to achieve
something
so part of what you're touching on there
is leadership in a sense of how do you
deliver inspiring leadership to be able
to
create that sense of shared purpose and
how do you kind of
unlock that and bring people
to that shared vision
having an efficient heating system
or something like that
to everyone who might benefit and um
right enough you know a lot of people
will be on social media and whatnot but
if you limited to that then you'll miss
a lot of other people yeah yes you
wouldn't just do one line of comms would
you you'd you'd cover the whole
yeah
yeah
yeah exactly to your audience yeah
without your audience
can i
ask you a lady's name
what's your experience then
trying to get that communication
across
what
potentially stumbling blocks
one of the stumbling blocks
that
comes flashing at the moment is
people's perception so their own rigid
point of view and how you get that
information out
into the public arena that is in an
acceptable way for them to take it on
board so that they do feel as though
rather than it being dictatorial or
a hugely embarrassing opinion
um
or something that they perceive because
um
hands up
perhaps i would i would definitely have
a left green political leading that
might put a huge amount of people off
looking at anything that i want to write
or say
um
so that comes back to that sharing
regardless of what level are you
prepared to put yourself out of the way
and
listen
so how would you feel for example how do
you think this something like this might
work if the
parish council
were thinking hey a local energy system
would be fantastic
um we've had some initial feasibility
studies done now we're going to go along
to we're going to approach the local
schools we're going to go to the pta
meeting
and we're going to not say we're doing
it we're not doing it but we're going to
give a
a presentation on the benefits of
community energy and is it
would something like that do you think
make it easier to access different
sections of the community where you
already have
organized groups who are interested in
in this instance their their children
and be involved with the school or being
involved with the play group where you
have people who are already
quite
committed and engaged with
community
for me i'm interested in something
called
deep adaptation
and practical deep adaptation and
how we actually move forward in a
massive way which
the the is
part of that is about community and it
just is
you have to build community in whatever
way you do
and
in terms of
climate emergency which is really
authorizing it's about identifying all
those different groups all those
different individuals in your
locality
but it's having a completely different
mindset
and that i'm struggling with how do you
do that i'm really struggling with it do
you think some of the issues might not
just be around i think it might not just
be around um
[Music]
people's views or positions but might be
around something as seemingly simple as
time i mean we have this in in our work
spaces is there something perhaps around
you know people thinking i really like i
like the idea of this green energy
project and
i kind of then i feel i could probably
help a bit but i'm just not sure i want
to commit myself because i might get
sucked in and end up having to do masses
so
maybe i'll just kind of push about on
the sidelines and support it and but
don't actually put any time or
um of my time to it do you think there's
a kind of
um
fear of
committing time
um in some instances or am i just
putting words into people's mouths
no i don't i don't think so i think
what you were saying about these
adaptations
it's too big
that's
you know it isn't too bad you just said
it's too difficult i can't comprehend
[Music]
and the more community based
sort of
interactions going on so you support
each other and that's where social care
will come in that's what we used to do
but it's that it's that too big a
concept and just
because it's kind of stressful
it's a wonderful shifting everything
yeah that's yeah i was kind of struck by
what you said earlier say and just
whilst we snatched a few minutes before
we came over here um so you're looking
for somebody who can maybe help
um point you in the right direction what
are we going for are we going for air
source heat pumps or should we be
thinking solar or you know where should
i be pushing my energy um
and if i got a consultant in or a
project manager i'd have to pay fees for
that
information
money that we might not have within the
community um and yet if you've got how
many people did you say lived in your
was it how many people yeah
so of those two and a half thousand and
all their relatives there is definitely
somebody within that that grouping who
maybe has project management skills or
um so that kind of goes back to what
nick was saying about how do you access
that
all of that resource that you have
within your community and that knowledge
that you have within your community
because it's unlikely that these people
are going to step forward isn't it and
it'll just end up being
um
you know you guys
working jolly hard burning the midnight
oil to to get something in which the
whole community will will benefit
greatly from and
so how do we how do we sort of in terms
of barriers to implementing these things
well it just so happens
the professional
project
oh i think i think he'll be all right
i think you've got a good in there yeah
but that's actually we've come back to
community because we had to talk to them
expertise within a community
and like i don't know my dad was good at
computers so he said i've met your
computer and he got back
somebody came into the garden so he's
going
way back with a different way of
trading as it were
[Music]
break it down
[Music]
you know we need it done
20 years ago you know yeah that's that's
that's
i'm not
all i'm doing is trying to think of a
solution and my immediate idea was to
break it down but you i know you're
you're
which people might feel a bit
angry about exactly why are you trying
to profile me and my abilities
rather than it being
altruistic goal for the benefit of all
so i think something
that's really helpful that's come out of
the suffolk climate plan
is there is a whole pathway in there
about working with um
working with community and some of the
funding that's been put into the plan
will go towards that but not in the ways
that you suspect it's not like a handout
for projects because there are you know
there's other money for that um but this
is to actually work on signposting how
do we set up
um systems and ways of communicating
with each other sharing across suffolk
sharing our skill sets our case studies
our resources a little bit like um
you know baby and mid-southwark have
done today which is you know amazing
they've done this two-day conference on
the renault to cop for
for the whole of suffolk um which has
opened up some of these conversations
we've met people we might not have mass
otherwise you know we're having
conversations where we may not agree
with everything that's been said
necessarily but we can take away the
bits that we think yeah you know that
works that works for us in our community
um
making it too big
is
type professional people that are used
to managing big projects or
understanding uh industry terminology
where you may have another younger
community or less affluent community
that doesn't have that level of
expertise or the level of understanding
so the way you approach both communities
absolutely yeah it's also
bringing it down to the local level
showing
maybe examples of good practice and as
you said with them as well you've got
there
you've got all the underfloor eating
that they've done come to another
village or that's made it the same age
but maybe serves less
a smaller community
but then saying well okay maybe the
elsewhere project is too big for what
you can offer but here's a scaled-down
version and here's somebody who's been
through the process
that's the sign posting bit and that's
why suffolk county council had tried to
go down that route because it is trying
to match people up like you say if i'm a
nip switch and i'm in a block of densely
packed flats um
my take trying to get everybody in my
block of flats engaged in community
energy suddenly my community is my block
of flats that's that's what i need to
address which is a completely different
thing from
[Music]
your butt so feel free to button
um
so what other kind of barriers do you
perceive other than that you know the
communication piece and obviously the
financial
aspects
we've looked at briefly at the
intellectual resource accessing
intellectual resource to actually do
this
in terms of
having a a strategy
how many of you guys know if you have a
neighborhood plan or
some kind of plan for
for your your parish cartilage
and so neighborhood plans came out about
10 12 years ago
which were an opportunity for
um communities to say
what they wanted in terms of development
for their
for their parish yeah i'm not sure
that's a great example because i think
there has been some disappointments with
the plan's
capacity to actually change
i yes hopefully that might
you know evolve a little further to work
maybe the plans have not cheap
but you know unfortunately
planning systems in a bit of flux
but just going back to community
and scale i mean i think sometimes we we
tend to see an enormous problem
that demands an enormous solution and
actually
sometimes the solution to the enormous
problem isn't an
enormous
[Music]
to change the world
but
be realistic about what we actually can
do
so maybe
steps to build capacity and confidence
to kind of build on and move forward
um a little bit like the net zero
journey itself you know 2050
or 2030 we're not suddenly going to
arrive there in one big blob it's got to
be done
um
over time so
and i think
that sort of came across quite nicely
when you looked at um
oh where was the project
he said it later isn't he um
uh the chat from
somewhere well no not well
yes
and but that's kind of how they did it
didn't they they started with
looking at our source heat pump just in
one part of
um you know their village hall and the
sports center the leisure center and
then 10 years later they were like okay
yeah we're good with this this works we
can we know how to do this we've done
this before and now they're
sort of really incredibly um
ambitious but in a way that is going to
be successful you know they're building
10 affordable homes on a shared energy
network and running a community pub but
that's not something that they just do
straight into they've slowly built up um
that sort of internal knowledge and that
community knowledge
but of course
if you look at the timeline of all of
that you're talking kind of 15 years
between if not slightly more from when
they started that process to getting to
where they are now um
and obviously that you know in 15 years
time will be in
2036 or so
and
yeah so that that scalability and going
back to the speed so
moving forward in a bite-sized way but
keeping the pace going um
across the whole of the
the region
and i think i think better
but just to let you know um with all of
this we're going to take this back into
the university it's going to form part
of the project that's all right with you
and for students to be able to look at
this and see
what kind of things
uh community yourself if it sells um in
terms of a focus group
what sort of things you think are the
challenges
and barriers
yes thank you sorry sorry we're good